monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale Monsieur
hatal Merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Louis
Vogel un enseignant sur deux déclare
s'être déjà autocensuré dans ses
enseignements par crainte des réactions
ou de
représailles lié à ses enseignements
c'est dire combien le phénomène est
structurant il concerne vous l'avez dit
les professeurs d'histoire géographie il
peut aussi concerner des professeurs de
lettres des professeurs de Ph phie des
professeurs de sciences de la vie et de
la terre dans un certain nombre de
d'enseignement ce phénomène nous devons
le regarder en face et nous devons être
absolument
implacable si nous voulons lutter contre
l'autocensure la première des choses à
faire c'est d'être en toute circonstance
au côté de nos enseignants en les
soutenant lorsqu'ils font face à ces
situations qu' les signale et en étant
exemplaire en matière de sanction c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose
c'est de rappeler toujours en toute C
constance ce qui n'est pas toujours fait
que la relation entre un enseignant et
ses élèves ça n'est pas une relation
d'égal à égal il y a celui qui sait et
qui a l'autorité de son savoir et il y a
ceux qui apprennent ça paraît comme cela
l'évidence mais malheureusement ça n'est
pas l'évidence ou ça n'est plus
l'évidence partout dans notre pays il
est nécessaire de toujours le rappeler
la troisième chose et vous l'avez dit
c'est de travailler avec les enseignants
probablement pour quand c'est à leur
demande quand ça vient les soutenir dans
leur renseignement adapter parfois le
format de certains cours si ça leur
permet de prodiguer ces leçons en toute
sérénité il y a la possibilité ça a été
évoqué par des enseignants que j'ai
rencontré sur le terrain effectivement
sur certains sujets vous avez évoqué la
laïcité d'avoir le renfort de personnes
extérieures internes au ministère de
l'Éducation nationale nos formateurs
laïcité nos équipes laicité valeur de la
République dans l'érectorat qui
viendraient soutenir les enseignants à
l'occasion de ces cours à la demande
évidemment des enseignants concernés
pour décharger une partie du poids de la
responsabilité euh de cet enseignement
face euh à certains élèves ça fait
partie des pistes que je regarde et que
je travaille avec les organisations euh
syndicales représentatives des
enseignants mais je sais que je pourrais
compter sur la représentation nationale
pour avancer sur ce chantier qui est
fondamental pour notre école et donc
pour notre
République